by the way we've got some serious
grobanites
in the vsf wall and in our second
segment we'd like to play a game called
random fandom
where we see which one can get picked to
give a little grobanite love to mr
groban himself
i think that's a really fun idea okay
good i'm glad you're game for it
um happy belated 40th birthday by the
way
thank you very much thank you yeah weird
to have a birthday
in the middle of all of this this was i
was my
my balloons i sat on my floor i i had a
virtual
party you know i was able to see some
some friends and band and crew but all
all on zoom you have the same birthday
as your brother but you're four years
apart right
that's right yeah i was fully expecting
like a cowboy clown party
on my fourth birthday i had it all set
up my friends were coming over i had ice
cream cake
and my dad's like nope we're going in
the car we're going to the hospital and
uh you got a different present instead
so um yeah having a baby brother on my
birthday was a weird thing
we're like best friends now um did you
ever ask your parents
why this time of year nine months ago
seemed to be such a festive one in their
lives
i think um i don't want to just be
totally weird about it but i think it's
like
my mom's birthday right you know yeah
so i i i don't know my parents have been
together
you know 50 years so uh
i i would imagine it's more than just
birthdays but you know who knows
your show is just is like it's prozac
it's like it is so hap makes me so happy
uh
you know but i mean medically don't you
know it's like i can't prescribe
a tv show to people but um but it makes
me so happy to watch your show your
energy is so infectious
and um and i am not i'm not you know a
morning person generally but just being
awake and talking to you it's just like
my day's gonna be great you know when we
did this show
and we started we were all learning a
new normal
and when you talked about how the
transition was when you had performed
virtually
and you weren't able to hear any
response whatsoever
i picture crickets on tumbleweeds like
riding through the wild west
how was that for you because that's how
we started out too
yeah it's so i mean as you know so well
i mean having that bounce back and forth
with an audience to kind of tell you
how the energy is going and where you
want to you know drift right and left
and
um you know my whole entire life since i
was 17 years old was
being put in front of an audience and
kind of walking that that
tightrope walk and so you know being put
in front of a camera and saying okay you
got 90 minutes to do a show
and um you know there's no worse
nightmare for a singer than finishing
like a really big note and just hearing
nothing afterwards just absolute
crickets you have to like imagine that
the
thousands of people around you know the
world are are clapping in their
living rooms and there was something
poetic about it i'm in a little box in
burbank and i'm singing you know to god
knows who's out there and
and we're all in these little boxes
around the world and um you find out
later i'm sure you do too you find out
on
on social media and stuff how much
people enjoyed the show and what it
meant to them and you realize how many
people
tuned in from countries that i'd never
been to in my entire life and you think
about the access
uh of being able to do a show for for
people that i might i not not have been
able to tour for
uh if it was in person so um you realize
that there's actually some magic to it
i can't wait to get to a live audience
but you know you make the most of it
another thing that i loved
is that you like to hit a baseball
stadium in almost every city that you
tour is this true
yeah so when i get to tour during the
summer there's no it's
truly there's there is no greater and
more fun thing than just doing a bunch
of outdoor venues when you're when
you're touring over the summer
and when you have a day off like i'm a
big baseball fan i grew up in l.a some
i'm dodger blue but i
but i love no angels love baseball
rivals but but lots of respect amazing
team i mean some of the best players
in the country uh but uh but no i just
you got see i feel like
with baseball rivalry i feel like you
have to be a fan of the team your like
your
your dad took you to you know as like a
kid you know you have to be a part of
the team like you're you're
you know you saw when you were little
and got the foam finger and had the hot
dog like that's
that's what's in your veins for your
whole life and i i'm in new york a lot
of the time and i'll go see
yankee games and stuff but um but yeah
but when i'm in when i'm touring in a
town and there's a baseball game going
on i don't care who's playing i just
like
going to the stadium i like kind of
feeling the the vibe of it i missed that
let me know we almost said a lot
well i got excited again i related to
you because i hit a museum
in every city that i tour and so i was
like i
know and and when you're working you
know you
they you kind of go in you land you run
to the hotel you do the show
and you leave the next morning and when
you're on a press tour or a music tour
i'm sure this schedule is somewhat
similar and so you're trying desperately
to
make the most of your time there and you
kind of get to do one
extracurricular thing if you can squeeze
it in there and so
i love that you did that because i know
i understand that
lifestyle and i'm really excited about
your new
album which is harmony deluxe
um it's a collection of songs that i've
loved for a very very long time as a
singer you kind of
you get kind of a bucket list of songs
you wanted to interpret and wanted to
sing for a long time fans request
for a very very long time and uh and
then there were a couple of originals
too that came from just being at home
and at a piano for this last year this
is the first time i've ever had to
record an album
where ever almost everything was virtual
where i'm here in the orchestras in
london
and producers in nashville and you know
it's again very detached but
at the same time for all of us to have
you know the energy to make it all come
together and that's
kind of why we called the album harmony
um it was uh
really a difficult but but inspiring
process to get it all
coming out of the speakers the way we
wanted well i
really like how you got so inventive in
this last year
and i am not an idol person nor can i
ever be and the fact that you were
getting back on garageband
and just reaching out to people going
okay i've got this to this point
in the song who else can i join to take
it to the end and the collaboration and
the innovative
innovation i just thought was super cool
it you know it's it's um it's it's
fun when you when you can utilize those
tools
for for good things there's some so much
time we waste time with the technology
over the years and this has been a time
where i think everybody has tried to
take the time by themselves to learn a
new skill to
you know brush up on production skills
or cooking or co-writing or whatever it
is and so
i i in this otherwise very traumatic
year i'm going to take the silver
linings of the things that i
i kind of tried to get better at yeah